good evening ladies and gentlemen I'm
Chris Hemsworth and I'm going undercover
on the Internet
it's actually it's not it's Liam
Hemsworth guys gotcha
Cora but Chris Evans who's Hemsworth win
in an arm wrestle
I have won in an arm wrestle he is
actually only about four foot three I
think so they have to enlarge him on
screen so I yeah that's that's an easy
one
how did you get Castor's thought I had a
very early audition Billy on the process
didn't go very well my little brother
had an audition he almost got the part
and didn't because I said he's a bit
young so they opened the casting back up
I was really angry that he almost got a
part so I came back in with a newfound
fury and actually had to call him and
say how was the audition give me some
tips and he did thankfully and I got the
part so it was very collaborative family
event that one motivated by a little bit
of brotherly rivalry it's actually me
what type of white training did Chris
Hemsworth do to prepare for for just
lots and lots of heavy whites isolated
muscle grouping power looking sort of
stuff my training now is a little more
functional and I'm not so worried about
getting massive as I'm about kind of
just staying fit and functional - how
heavy is Chris Hemsworth pop hammer it's
extremely heavy about 436 pounds
how much mean Chris Hemsworth been
dressed
I don't been pressed at all I did a lots
of push-ups so whatever I why the math
is there but for the first order I've
been tracing a lot to be boring exercise
and pretty useless unless you have to do
this - too bad guys you know done
answers no seriously it's actually me
when did Chris Hemsworth start acting um
you know I've always made a bit of a
lawyer and from a very very young age
and mostly to gonna remove myself from
various duties around the house I'd
pretend to be sick or broken in some way
and incapable of doing any real work
that's where it all started posted he's
Chris Hemsworth ticklish a little bit
answered IMDB my trademarks a deep
resonant voice light old blue eyes
muscular physique and confused
just a big kid I guess ridiculous
born August 11 1993 correct nickname kid
yeah when I was very little it was hyped
six foot two or three quarters up and on
I think I'm about six or three actually
but it's close enough for now it's
official let's go do it
I swear to you it's actually me chris
hemsworth my I asked if you were to
choose boxing or kung fu which integers
I know a lot of boxing Muay Thai and
kickboxing but do you know give kung fu
ago if if it's beneficial chris
hemsworth have you seen this what do you
thought and it says Chris Hemsworth is
Australian and for is from space does
that make him and Australian hilarious
it does in fact yeah yep yep Australian
YouTube Sunday full trailer here we go
okay so I didn't get it it's not a movie
they got like half a dozen big names to
star in a fake movie trailer
well how they managed that I was gonna
make a fake trailer maybe Tom Hanks is
available well if you can afford Tom
Hanks I'm sure just was the Australian
Tourism campaign they basically wrangled
a whole lot of Australians who were keen
to promote their beautiful country and
then Jenny McBride who deep down wants
to be Australian so we got him for free
well there we have it folks
we're done